there's been a long love-hate
relationship with cities that big and
messy in new york city or in shanghai
it's easier to go up 300 meters than it
is to travel horizontally 300 meters
during much of the day if we don't find
the solutions in cities then we're going
to have a hard time finding the
solutions because that's where most of
people are living and that is going to
increasingly be the case cities emerged
about 10,000 years ago the conventional
wisdom is that when we move to settled
agriculture 10,000 years or so guard
cities or towns that were began to grow
as agglomerations of population to do
with the division of labor the
increasing surplus in society and so on
and you know for for thousands of years
technological constraints limited the
size of cities humans since ever in all
settings travel about 70 minutes per day
whether it's rice farmers going to their
fields students going to elementary
schools or commuters in fact the best
definition of a city i think is the area
that you can reach in 35 minutes and
then get back home again that is to say
that from the center to the periphery
that that round trip of about 70 minutes
which is about what people are willing
to travel each day really defines an
urban area we're crossing the fifty
percent of the world population living
in cities now that is in the developed
world already up to eighty eighty-five
percent and since the developed world
countries are creating many of the
environmental problems that we're seeing
globally now that level of urbanization
is something to really think about in
terms of how do we have to modify our
theory in order to take into account the
prevalence and predominance of this one
species human species that inhabit
certain ecosystems
china is a living laboratory of rapid
urban growth the world's most populous
country got a late start on urbanization
but is catching up quickly today around
forty five percent of the population
lives in cities the sheer scale of this
extreme makeover is enormous some eighty
nine cities of million people and seven
city said more than five million people
this rapid urbanization has caused some
significant problems I'm strolling down
a hoot on a rare and vanishing example
of a traditional Beijing neighborhood
people here heat their homes using coal
in fact coal consumption coal combustion
is the predominant form of energy
electricity and hot water heating here
in Beijing today the air is quite
breathable but some days the air reeks
of sulfur and the pea soup is like
London of the early 20th century no
wonder then that Beijing officials worry
about air quality for the upcoming
summer olympics but really it's the most
vulnerable the very young the elderly
who are at risk from this very heavy
pollution burden the environmental
Kuznets curve is very simple initially
richer is dirtier and then later richer
is cleaner when first when people first
start to have higher incomes they chew
through lots of stuff they chop down
lots of trees they burn coal they make a
make a mess but then when they in turn
get a bit richer after that cleanliness
environment safety those values become
more important and they have the
resources to invest so you have a kind
of art where with rising incomes
initially life the economy cities become
dirtier and then later on they become
cleaner and I think what we're seeing in
many societies now is a very very strong
preference for a rising share of
people's wealth and income to be
dedicated to Environmental Quality
the misconception is that there is a
nature out there and then there is a
society over here and so if people are
living in cities they're not living in
nature they're not living in an
ecosystem in an ecological system and in
fact that's not the case urban
environments are ecosystems they have
living and nonliving components that
interact they are areas that in which
ecological processes are going on all
the time we can learn a lot from looking
at urban ecosystems in the same way that
we look at other ecosystems but what we
have learned in years of study of urban
ecosystems is that we can't ignore the
fact that they are dominated by one
species this human species and that we
have to use the tools and approaches
that have been developed in social
sciences to really understand the
interactions between the social system
and the ecological system
if you look at city plans they're still
rather top-down rather idealistic they
don't really relate to what cities are
actually like as it were but of our
scientific viewers begun to change that
it's much more to do with the fact that
this kind of messiness of cities is is
effectively a manifestation of a kind of
underlying order and that we need to
take this into account so that's a
change that's going on at the moment and
in fact if you look at the on my on my
computer screen here I have a picture of
London which is the London the form of
London something like 40 miles across
and 40 miles north it's the actual
picture of the spread of the city and it
looks like a kind of a cancer it looks
messy looks angry and that's been the
predominant view of cities I think from
all sorts of perspectives but and that's
the thing that's begun to change
recently so the digital world is giving
this as this ability to learn more about
cities but at the same time of course we
have to be conscious of the fact that
cities are also responding and changing
to the very existence of this digital
world it's kind of two-way traffic I
mean we get to know more about the city
but the same time cities are changing
with response to these technological
technological developments now in terms
of actually thinking about cities
thinking about how we might go about
communicating these ideas to people then
clearly the idea of representing the
city digitally is important and again
I'm looking at this movie of Canary
Wharf here and you can actually see that
this effect effectively is like a a land
use plan showing you the location of
different land uses in the world but
it's also in 3d and we can manipulate it
we can fly through it because we can put
it on the web we can actually
communicate the plan to a whole range of
people in a very effective way now that
is something which is very new and in a
digital world where we have the ability
to link large numbers of people to this
sort of these sort of visualizations
then that's a very effective
beginning to think about a kind of a
planning of cities that involves a much
wider constituency of people than we've
ever had the ability to do previously
the 20th century experienced in my view
of the great misfortune of the the
development of the suburbs I don't like
the suburbs I regard suburban Knights as
castrated peasants you can't even keep a
chicken in the suburbs for fear that the
neighbors will complain because of the
noise so I hope that we'll see in the
21st century decline in that environment
and again a rise of true and beautiful
cities the American writer Gertrude
Stein in about the year nineteen thirty
remarked that at that time in 1930 the
United States was the oldest country in
the world because the United States had
been in the 20th century longer than any
other country and in 2008 I would say
that cities like Hong Kong and Shanghai
and Bangalore have now been in the 21st
century longer than London or Paris or
New York or Chicago and so I think we
really need to look to these new cities
for experience and models we will cities
be 10 years from now 20 years from now a
century from now expect in the near
future eco-cities to arise these cities
will use renewable resources to try to
reduce their carbon footprint the ratio
of the carbon they emit to the carbon
that's absorbed in the city it's
heartening to imagine that humanity can
summon the courage to radically rethink
our concept of cities and create living
spaces in harmony with nature before
this vision can be fully realized
however we must solve the problems the
many discouraging problems of the urban
lifestyle that three billion of us have
chosen to lead today scientists must
take the lead in helping to draw up the
blueprints for the sustainable cities of
the future in this special issue on
cities find news reviews and
perspectives on urbanization health
reproduction traffic
Shin water energy and much more
you
science is published by triple ass the
science society